real talk and I'm being a hundred
percent serious here I think a lot of
people judge this they judge this
opinion but I'm being 100% serious when
I say this I think Nicolas Cage is the
greatest living American actor and I
know you're laughing I'm being dead
serious when I tell you this Nicolas
Cage no no no no no you gotta check the
facts dude I said living I said living I
said leave me out of character I mean
this sincerely like I understand has
become kind of like a joke or whatever
but if you look at the body of his work
if you look at the body of his work
where you want to start you want to
start two titties we're sorry the
treasure national treasure titties right
natural treasure too one time it's a fun
time it's so good but because of him
he's doing tricks into high jinks he's
doing English accents to get him out of
things right he's finding a map he's
putting on the glasses there's more [ __ ]
in the map selling high jinks this Bugs
Bunny mother's going to be doing hi Jo
that's how great Nicholas was he could
you know take that that could be his
motivation
realtor and I know people think that I'm
crazy the greatest living American actor
Marlon Brando was he American he dad
though dad dad dad there's other guys De
Niro De Niro No De Niro not as good as
Nicolas Cage okay alright I think I know
where you're going
Nicolas today was amazing De Niro Pacino
is amazing at being Pacino right Nicolas
Cage yeah can be anything hmm
a motorcycle guy with a skull fire head
that movie was kind of fun he makes
something for everyone national treasure
one national treasure - did they do a
third probably maybe okay think about it
gone in 60 seconds
okay tell me that wasn't fire it was
fire when I was that she'll be a duty
the relationship he had sorry about
Angelina
Oh smoker out smoker out [ __ ] smoke
bomb she came out like me right okay I'm
not all the way on board yet but I'm
rolling okay look you guys alright
the plane hijacked movie where they
break out a [ __ ] Hard Rock Cafe sign
it repels in it bro okay Conair here now
they're flying the it's a Plane full of
convicts John Malkovich John Malkovich's
like it's the virus you know it is the
virus first app since Corona we're back
don't be soft
duh get at it okay check it Bonaire
spider-man into the spider-verse
who was he Google Peter Parker and
spider-man noir that's something you
don't even know about Nic Cage Nic Cage
will be his [ __ ] - Julianne [ __ ] know
about ok Conair didn't he do something
with dead man walking didn't he win an
Oscar for that there's another one I
recall nice to know - waiting for you to
say - one
oh gee move leaving Las Vegas oh there
we go sorry
okay we're gonna get to face off in a
second but did some like Las Vegas movie
leaving Las Vegas leaving Las Vegas I
see it but people spoke about it no no
but that one breath apparently it was
good I've never won an Oscar
no I heard critical darling say it
he got leaving Las Vegas the one where
he's on death row not enough of a comedy
maad people like Raising Arizona oh my
god son oh my god bleep on Nick Nick the
quick cake myth the quick is out here
who the [ __ ] is sleeper hold when you
thought you're like oh this the best
actor is Robert Q tapping out what mark
Fast Times at Ridgemont High you can't
make that move without Nick serving the
burgers son so you see mad Nicolas Cage
movies we all have face-off let me just
tell okay Loki we all have fam how the
dynamic I mean how dynamic an actor are
you with face-off you start as good guy
bad guy you know yeah you start as bad
guy switch that up good guy seamless you
don't even notice that they're like it's
amazing how that acting was unbelievable
unbelievable I saw some indie movie with
him adaptation oh my god anymore eight
are you on his IMDB just know where Amy
named a random movie you right you want
to random my boy just go like this and
then stop it up the ant bully what
prolific my man is go like this and then
stop and they hit it going all right but
a good one who stopped to go back these
are kind of bomb snake I never bombed
all right what about a Amos and Andrew I
was probably going snake eyes what was
that one snake eyes
some about boxing and casinos I didn't
watch it to be honest but look all I'm
saying is Nic Cage gets slept on hmm he
is without a doubt liquor man bro
what weaker man that already listen mark
liquor man we'd said weaker man before I
understand there are certain things
about Nicolas Cage that you judge him by
okay he's had a horrible hairpiece his
entire career Oh Ohio
look I know it looks like a tumbleweeds
first that's what is here Lee goes like
this just this one movie I'm gonna say
it I'm gonna leave it here you guys
decide what you feel about it the rock
oh [ __ ] the rock is hot y'all escape
that movie where they escape from the
trash [ __ ] they got a sweet dish it is
hot fiery oh let escape in the Rock and
Sean Connery oh my god biggest actor
that made like the most straight-to-dvd
movies cuz I don't think these are in
the movies were in the nation massive
sensation at some point he was making
like 20 plus million a movie he had a
lot of flops so we realtalk all jokes
aside he had a lot of flops so we forget
how many measures yeah he didn't have a
lot of flops he didn't have a lot of
flops he released movies like albums you
know I'm saying he put out nine movies
ten movies that's the album that's the
album he put it all at the same time you
know he got a couple of singles in there
he got a couple bangers and then he got
a couple amos and Andy's that's how he
works but he can do comedy he can do
drama he can do action he did a movie
where he was like he did some indie [ __ ]
he did a movie where he was like a
robber and then this girl like says he's
she's his daughter and it's like some
crazy la yep and then you gotta you
gotta get his daughter back yeah I'm
like you gotta get his daughter back
you got to stop his robbing ways it's
something like that yeah something like
and then he's all like I love you I love
you what I wasn't there for you because
I was Robin Robin and [ __ ] the one son
Nick Cage is all boss so which movie do
you think would be a no this is
important boxes box it was trash message
me on Instagram by the box [ __ ] he goes
I'm not gonna lie I'm English and that
was scintillating pasta about us but I
was loving every minute blown up in
London which movie is better with Nick
Cage in it Ok Go which one you think oh
god father Citizen Kane the Citizen Kane
if he was Kane that she was slapped fact
is mad gold 80s I was watching a play of
it 1941 son I don't even know what I
hate color is it gonna be sound I have
been watching to preview for it you can
watch the previous because we looked at
every oscar-winning film yeah and we
were like you hella boy we're more like
what a [ __ ] to watch and we saw Citizen
Kane and then there's another 12 angry
madam funky thinks it's if Kane was the
80s time don't matter but it's like
dollars was 100 I think about it I'm
doubling down on that I think it was if
Snickers was five cents back then
back when Snickers with five cents back
then and now it's a dollar how much was
King Snickers in the eighties
do that math mark found we got to share
with the people yeah apparently there
was a a Negro baseball team in Atlanta
called the Atlanta black crackers the
ABC yo war market jerseys they were
really good they were good people like
them over the best team in the league or
something like that you're saying the
crackers were busting all the other
bikes yeah what do you think's more
famous now on the podcast for his exhale
we're supposed to be solid when they
make fun of every other race and
religion but that is so [ __ ] sure so
have we proved that Nic Cage is the
greatest living
I didn't say dead living I make the case
Nick Cage is better than he's not better
than Kevin Spacey Kevin Spacey that's
what I was gonna bring up
were you really yeah okay Kevin Spacey
is the best I will give you that Kevin
Spacey's the best that's Macy's cuz the
kid didn't say what cuz the kid did I
ain't never he never touched kids yes he
did no he didn't the boy was like 14 no
18 no he wasn't he was but once you see
today you become 18 the closets like a
gay bar mitzva you're an adult now in
the eyes of gays they're ready to feed
but I think the guy was 18 nah now he
was like 15 he was 18 or 17 I heard 14
maybe 15 like what story did you make it
mark stop act like you don't know this
by heart bro come on then at the bottom
of the story brother was the kid
[Laughter]
there you go uh he was oh my god the
kids last name is RA P whoa rap yeah
yeah okay and he said he was 14 what
happened what happened he might have
been at a party there we suppose making
sexual advances yeah that's a little
crazy Frank Underwood Barbara yeah your
[ __ ] fourteen-year-old studied Double
Down no like what he like came out as
Frank Underwood and made like oh I'm
i'ma get all the people's talking bad
about me did you see that was the
realest [ __ ] ever since so funny you
imagine Loki imagine uh who the [ __ ]
played Thanos Josh Brolin yeah imagine
Josh Brolin called me too and he came
out they're like listen if you will make
this disappear you gonna come out and
character brah that's working uh what's
that guy pee-wee's Playhouse that's what
he should have done what he was jerking
off in the movie theater yeah he should
just come out as [ __ ] peewee there's
way like talk regular makeup the [ __ ]
out here peewee total right yeah yeah
and you mean it just goes hey kid hello
I like coca-cola and uh some fries like
he'll save that sentence nah he's trying
to diddle [ __ ] I thought that's what he
was putting on accent when he was in
blow yo he was in Buffy the Vampire
Slayer
that's a slept on [ __ ] show sign show
remove had a movie son that's a slept on
movie you know directed that Nicholas
you can't argue it Nicolas Cage is like
is he like Francis Ford Coppola son
that's what I'm saying
that's good stuff yeah who are these
people phrase before he made the for
email Carver yes not his son hopefully
son son you never had if there's a Ford
you've never heard of Ford's Ford
Mustang for Coppola 78 Coppola is like
the [ __ ] iconic is B car yeah iconic
car come on bro we think cos put you to
backup and where do they take you okay
[Music]
[Applause]